bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
fois n'est pas coutume je vais féliciter
monsieur macron pour son éclair de
lucidité oui vous nous emmerdez depuis
cinq ans
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ces
caches une émission consacrée cette
semaine aux gros titres de l'actualité
économique au menu donc le variant
omicron et bercy qui renforce ses aides
pour venir en aide aux entreprises on
parlera de cette vague de fusions
acquisitions qui a déferlé en france en
2021 et puis au sommaire un anniversaire
celui de l'euro et qui fête ses 20 ans
on va évoquer à tout cela avec vous
olivier a bien évidemment bonjour
olivier bonjour et puis face à vous
nathalie jenson économistes et
enseignante chercheuse à l'école de
management neoma business school bonjour
natale et bonjour et bienvenue sur ce
plateau merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation on va commencer à part ce qui
occupe beaucoup à l'actualité c'est le
variant omicron fin décembre jean castex
a annoncé de nouvelles mesures
restrictives pour tenter d'endiguer
cette vague ainsi les aides pour les
entreprises affectés par les
restrictions sanitaires vont être
renforcée et élargie sépia notamment
dans le secteur du tourisme avec le
grand retour du chômage partiel sans
reste à charge les bases du
déclenchement de ce dispositif sont
élargies et toutes les entreprises qui
auront perdu 65 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires contre 80 % jusqu'à présent
pourront en bénéficier pour le
dispositif de prise en charge des coûts
fixes réservé jusqu'à présent un nombre
limité d'entreprises sera quant à lui
élargie à l'ensemble des entreprises du
tourisme le seuil d'accès à ce
dispositif est lui aussi abaissé à 50 %
de perte de chiffre d'affaires contre 60
5% auparavant olivier est ce que cela
signifie concrètement que c'est le
retour à une économie sous perfusion
abba totalement ici il ya quelques il ya
quelques mois quand bruno le maire avait
annoncé la fin ou sonné du quoi qu'il en
coûte et bien un jld avait ri jaune mais
jamais ri en disant que
évidemment le quoi qu'il en coûte ne
s'arrêtait pas est bien la preuve en est
c'est que non seulement il ne s'arrête
pas mais c'est encore j'irai pire
qu'avant et est aujourd'hui on est
obligé à cause des mesures qu'ils
prennent c'est pas le covin n'y est pour
rien là dedans le pauvre petit virus ne
bloque pas l'économie c'est bien il a
bloqué qui
il ya de mou nouvelles mesures
restrictives d'accord mais c'est
justement à cause de ces nouvelles
mesures restrictives que vous avez
besoin de soutenir l'économie et de la
remettre sous perfusion donc vous la
mettez sous perfusion on sait que de
toute façon on l'a dit dit fois alors
visiblement c'est pas encore rentré dans
la tête des énarques mais quand l'état
paye c'est qu'il est assez vous c'est
nous donc on va le payer d'une manière
ou d'une autre dans les impôts dans ce
que vous voulez mais ça n'est que un
déplacement finalement d'argent pour
soutenir une économie qui est moribonde
depuis longtemps mais ça fait plaisir à
monsieur le maire de pouvoir annoncer
encore une fois que la croissance est
extraordinaire en france la croissance
c'est surtout la croissance de la dette
qui est extraordinaire en france et et
la croissance de la dépense publique
mais la dépense publique il ya quelqu'un
qui la règle et je vous dis c'est nous
alors oui de toute façon en partie il
est vrai que là on ne fait qu'accumuler
des des plans dead et comme vous l'avez
justement souligné parce
qu'effectivement comme le gouvernement
décide d'arrêter certains secteurs en
tout cas de limiter leurs activités là
pour le coup il crée un effet unesco
appelle une externe est négative liée
aux qu'ovide et dans ce cas il n'y a pas
vraiment d'autre choix puisqu'il
l'imposent secteur privé de les
compenser là on peut pas dire
qu'effectivement pourtant j'ai une
position plutôt assez libérale en
général mais là lorsqu'une lorsque c'est
une restriction d'activité imposées par
l'état je vois pas comment effectivement
l'état pourrait ne pas en fait compensé
pour cette baisse d'activité
ce qui est regrettable
ici c'est que en effet on va prendre des
heavy d'amendé plan de soutien enfin on
va donner des accords d'aidé au soutien
des entreprises qui sont directement
touchés mais en fait il ya plein
d'activités qui vont être indirectement
touchés et qui à nouveau ça va donner
lieu à bas pourquoi pas moi et pourquoi
pas pourquoi les autres parce que
objectivement ils ont une activité
restreinte mais néanmoins cela n'empêche
pas les effets collatéraux négatifs
on peut penser à la restauration qui par
l'effet du télétravail va se retrouver à
nouveau effectivement baisse d'activité
et j'imagine qu'ils seront aussi
éligibles donc on rentre à nouveau dans
un cercle en effet infernal dead qui
n'en finit pas et on se demande jusqu'où
sa balle est dans une année prédit un
moment préélectorale on se doute bien on
a bien vu avec le chèque inflation déjà
lorsque tout semblait redevenir normal
qu'on était à nouveau en train de
compenser quelque chose qui à priori
n'avait pas lieu d'être donc
effectivement ça pose des questions mais
justement on est revenu sur un semi quoi
qu'il en coûte on était passé assure du
sur mesure avant là on revient à des add
élargi quel impact ça sur l'économie
concrètement de faire un peu de haine et
n'offrent comme ça alors en général
c'est pas très bon enfin on vous dit que
pour la pour que les entreprises en fait
tu puisses
pouvoir prévoir pas se projeter dans le
temps c'est vrai que du que du stop and
go comme ça n'est jamais très très bon
puisque ça désorganise tout simplement
vous avez des gens qui vont revenir
finalement sur leur lieu de travail
qu'il faut finalement nous avons pu être
là donc vous avez effectivement des
coups des coups de cacher en fait qu'on
qui savent qu'on verra plus dans le long
terme puisque on verra comment les
entreprises vont se constituer maison
que se comporter par rapport à ces
décisions qui vont et qui viennent bon
je pense que beaucoup appris en fait à
anna vivent au jour le jour mais le prix
du jour le jour c'est qu'effectivement
on a du mal à ce projet à se projeter
dans le temps et donc ça peut être
nuisible en effet aux
projets d'investissement voilà ça c'est
là la partie la plus préoccupante 1
bruno le maire a aussi annoncé le report
du remboursement adp j'ai eu les prêts
garantis par l'état pour les tpe qui on
a des difficultés à rembourser ça
concerne de 25 à 30 me entreprises but
allemand pour ces entreprises pourra
aller jusqu'à 10 ans le début du
remboursement adp ge pourra se faire non
pas au printemps mais à la fin de
l'année 2022 fait la confédération des
pme plaide pour que le report et
l'étalement des remboursements soient
ouverts à toutes les entreprises
indépendamment de leur taille ou de leur
secteur d'activité olivier faut-il
effectivement élargir cette mesure vous
avez remplacé pendant quasiment pendant
deux ans vous avez remplacé de
l'activité par de la dette ce qui est
une aberration économiquement on sent
bien qu'il ya un truc qui va pas donc
vous avez remplacé de l'activité par la
dette et maintenant on bat que vous
allez demander parce que à un moment
sinon ça s'appelle pas après ça
s'appelle un don et donc vous allez
demander le remboursement du prêt et ils
savent très bien que le jour où ils vont
demander le remboursement du prêt bas
c'est fini c'est à dire toutes les
entreprises vont tomber parce qu'elles
ne pourront pas enfin pour beaucoup
elles ne pourront pas rembourser
et donc oui celles qui n'en avaient au
final pas besoin donc qui au prix un peu
un prêt garanti par l'état alors
qu'elles n'en avaient pas forcément le
le besoin mais sinon celle qui en avait
vraiment besoin aujourd'hui ne pourront
pas rembourser est ce qu'il faudrait
qu'il y ait un tel surcroît d'activité
si vous voulez pour pour pouvoir
rembourser le pge que elles ne pourront
pas le faire et à ce moment là on
assistera à des faillites alors c'est
pas la peine de se vanter comme le font
comme l'est le fait le gouvernement du
fait qu' il ya eu beaucoup moins de
faillites que prévu évidemment il ya eu
beaucoup moins de faillites que prévu
puisqu'on n'a pas demandé à hambourg
c'est qu'on a continué à apporter de
l'argent le jour où vous aurez
réellement la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte
et le jour où vous aurez réellement le
l'exigence d'un remboursement de ces pge
à ce moment là les entreprises vont
tomber comme des mouches donc ils le
savent c'est bien pour ça que maintenant
il reporte à chaque fois blessé en fait
c'est un défaut de paiement c'est saxon
c'est comme ça s'appelle tous les
secteurs
vous pouvez l'élargir à tous les
secteurs à ce moment là vous aurez vous
aurez le vous repousserait pour tous les
secteurs vous repousserait le moment où
le couperet va tomber c'est tout et donc
ça se transformera en personne née du ca
va se transformer en réel don
mais à ce moment là bien bien évidemment
c'est laisser les banques qui vont
commencer à avoir des difficultés on
voulait tenteront pas de toute façon
quoi qu'il arrive qu'on l'ait contraint
à des reports tunnel pourront pas le
faire donc et si vous reporter sans
arrêt c'est les banques que vous mettez
en difficulté parce que c'est elle qui
ont prêté l'état il a apporté sa
garantie d'accor mais elle c'est elle
qui ont prêté donc
vous avez vous avez un souci c'est que
vous pouvez pas effacer la dette comme
ça il ya un moment où si vous effacez la
dette vous avez des conséquences à ça
donc il ya un moment où il faut il
faudrait qui est quand même une vision
économique alors je sais bien que c'est
beaucoup demander à monsieur bruno le
maire qui n'a absolument aucune idée de
ce que c'est que l'économie mais c'est
enfin on va on va arriver sur des sur
des ddd moment où il va falloir prendre
des décisions parce que repousser tout
le temps c'est bien mais ça ne ça ne
change rien ça ne résout pas le problème
alors vous me direz ça fait 12 ans qu'on
fait ça depuis depuis 2008 on a
l'habitude d'enterrer la poussière sous
le tapis
c'est très bien simplement bas on le
voit assez régulièrement la poussière
elle a tendance à ressortir du tapis et
c'est là que on a des problèmes et
malgré tout bercy en reste confiant sur
les prévisions de croissance pour le
pays marron l'année avec un solide
acquis de 2 2% et notre économie
bénéficie à temps plein des réformes de
fond engagées depuis 2017 je maintiens
donc notre prévision de croissance pour
2022 à 4% déclarations de bruno le maire
le ministre de l'économie le 4 janvier
au figaro nathalie jenson malgré le
retour est d aide malgré cette vague du
hameau mikron le pays a les capacités de
maintien de maintenir cet objectif de
croissance selon lui
il ne pourra les maintenir si
effectivement on le laisse on le laisse
faire son activité dans des conditions
pas trop restrictives
là aussi et puis bien évidemment ça va
dépendre de la dynamique en termes de
continuité du soutien là comme il venait
d'évoquer leasing les histoires de
remboursement de pge ce qui est un petit
peu regrettable dans cette histoire
c'est que effectivement ce sont bien les
banques à qui enfin qu'ils ont bien
prêter et mais en fait la décision de
qui va rembourser ou qu'ils aient
prolongé leur échappe ce qui est un peu
ce qui est un peu étrange puisque c'est
quand même elle qui connaissent un peu
mieux leur métier qu'eux et c'est là
qu'on rencontre qu'on fait rentrer un
billet puisque on va demander un état de
10 rebonds et remboursent pas tout de
suite et des autres
selon calendrier alors qu'en fait les
banques voient bien en fait c'est pas
une histoire uniquement le secteur c'est
aussi une histoire de management il ya
je connais des entreprises et je crois
que tout le monde autour de nous que les
entreprises qui ont anticipé
remboursements parce que elle avait peur
elle n'avait pas envie de prendre de
haut si l'aide parce que c'était des
choses qu'elles qu'elles redoutaient
dépendent des aides et d'autres qui les
ont prises donc je pense que c'est tout
à fait regrettable d'avoir à la fois les
banques qui sont elles mêmes prêteuses
ce qui est normal et mais à qui on
enlève la décision de savoir qui en fait
plus remboursés à quel moment parce que
c'est quand même elle qui détient de
cette information de façon précise et
c'est là qu'on introduit effectivement
des effets d'opportunisme qui sont
nuisibles en fait pour cette reprise
économique puisque en fait ceux qui sont
plus opportunistes ont plus de chances
de mal terminée que ce qu'en fait nous
ne sont pas opportuniste et parfois bien
on va pas aider celles qui sont pas
opportuniste et aider celles qui le sont
donc c'est ce qui est regrettable qui
pourra avoir fn année un effet négatif
en fait à terme merci nathalie ont
remarqué une courte pause et on revient
dans un instant
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine
l'actualité économique et pour en parler
nous sommes avec un intelligent son
économiste et enseignante chercheuse à
l'école de management neoma business
school on change de registre à présent
je vous le disais l'euro fête ses 20 ans
cette année on va commencer par un bilan
de l'arrivée de l'euro dans nos porte
monnaie c'est avec le tiroir cash
d'antoine place
depuis le 1er janvier l'euro sous sa
forme fiduciaire à 20 ans alors quel
bilan pour les consommateurs français
les prix ont-ils réellement explosé
comme on le dit souvent en partie oui
entre 2002 et 2021 ils ont bondi de 31%
en gros ce qui coûtait 100 euros en 2002
coûte maintenant 131 euros en moyenne
cela fait une inflation de 1,3 pour cent
par an une inflation présente mais bien
moins importante qu entre 86 et 2001 où
a été de 2,1 pour cent par an et
qu'entre la précaire des années 80 où
elles atteignaient plus de 10% par an
des chiffres fournis par l'insee à
relativiser puisqu'il se cale sur l'
indice des prix à la consommation qui
s'appuie sur un panier type et ne prend
pas en compte certaines données on vous
en avait déjà parlé dans ces caches mais
l'euro ce n'est pas que les prix à la
consommation en prenant compte
l'ensemble de l'économie et sa
prospérité en 2019 infime tank
bruxellois a établi que chacun de nos
voisins allemands avaient gagné 23
mixant 16 euros supplémentaires en vingt
ans grâce à l'instauration de la monnaie
unique pendant que nous français nous en
aurions perdu 55 1996 en gros nous
aurions eu en poche en moyenne chaque
mois 2 146 euros supplémentaires si le
franc était resté la monnaie du pays
[Musique]
olivier à l'euro c'est une devise qui a
fait ses preuves selon vous je ne savais
pas qu'il fallait fêter un enterrement
c'est à dire que
ça fait 20 ans qu'on subit l'euro et
dans le tiroir cash on démontre que il
ya des gagnants et des perdants les
gagnants incontestablement sont les sons
les allemands
et les perdants le reste c'est-à-dire
l'italie l'espagne la grèce portugal la
france et j'en passe et des meilleurs
donc
on a décidé à mon avis de la façon la
plus belle qui soit 2
regrouper un certain nombre de pays qui
n'avaient pas le même modèle économique
y avait des économies qui étaient très
divergentes et on leur a collé un
dénominateur commun qui est la monnaie
et qui est une monnaie qui est à mais on
le voit à créer des catastrophes et et
est probablement à la fin des fins à
disparaître donc c'est ce qu'on peut
probablement espérer mieux il faudrait
mieux le faire d'ailleurs de façon
contrôlée plutôt que d'attendre que ça
ça nous pète à la figure
l'euro est une mauvaise chose pour
l'instant moi je à chaque fois que je
rencontre un européiste je lui demande
ce que ça nous a apporté alors il finit
par bégayer que ça nous a apporté la
paix alors que ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'europe et l'euro mais que ça a plutôt
à voir avec la dissuasion nucléaire mais
ça évidemment ils oublient le conflit
dans les balkans aussi est mise à part
ça il n'y a pas grand chose si vous
voulez on nous avait quand même promis
plus de chômage j'ai pas vu que ça avait
eu un effet extraordinaire sur le
chômage on nous avait promis une
croissance extraordinaire je n'ai pas vu
non plus la croissance extraordinaire à
arriver donc je suis la réduction des
déficits la réduction
suis désolé mais le constat
malheureusement n'est pas le même que
que ceux qui chaussent leurs lunettes
roses pour regarder l'europe avec les
yeux de l'amour des gens font l'idea
nous dit que c'est une monnaie qui est
amené à créer des catastrophes est ce
que vous êtes d'accord je vais je vais
tempérer
je vais jouer le rôle voilà j'ai joué le
contre pouvoir ici alors je serai moins
sévère en effet vis-à-vis de l'euro en
effet dû toute façon l'euro est une
construction politique
voilà qui a été fait de façon volontaire
puisque au niveau économique ceux qui
ont travaillé sur ce qu on appelle les
zones monétaires optimales ces risques
un ensemble de pays peuvent partager une
même monnaie avait bien dit qu'il y
avait des critères à remplir notamment
en terme de circulation de fluidité pour
que tout se passe bien et ces critères
on ne les remplissaient pas dès le
départ donc on savait d'ailleurs ceux
qui en étaient à l'origine quitter donc
c'était robert mundell qui et qui est
décédé il ya peu d'ailleurs et puis
avait mackinnon fin d'ensemble
d'économistes habité avait avait émis
leurs leurs réserves en fait sur cette
cette volonté de vouloir y aller à tout
prix alors qu'on en était on est un
ensemble de pays qui somme toute ne sont
pas si convergents que ça économiquement
parlant mais l'idée de ceux qui ont
voulu cette construction de la monnaie
européenne s'était de dire le politique
fort sera l'économie et alors on voit
qu'effectivement finalement c'est
peut-être pas une si bonne chose puisque
on n'est pas arrivé à forcer c'était
très drôle en dans l'est pour les 10 ans
il ya eu un colloque aux états unis en
disant que finalement on s'était
peut-être trompé que le politique
pourrait forcer l'économie et puis ça a
été après on a eu la crise des dettes
souveraines donc bien non kate patatras
en fait finalement c'est pas ça non plus
donc voilà donc je pense
qu'effectivement il ya on a eu peur on a
une partie belle malgré tout même
partagé par l'italie la france et la
grèce qui a été avant les crises des
dettes souveraines donc cette ses dix
premières années ont plutôt été
favorable dans la mesure où on a arrêté
les dévaluations on a plutôt une
inflation plus de relativement faible et
les pays ont pu s'endetter donc la grèce
en particulier de façon moins coûteuse
puisque voilà elles ont elles ont pu
bénéficier de l'impact d'avoir la
monnaie unique plutôt que d'évaluer
comme c'était souvent le cas en france
en italie dans tous les pays plutôt du
cid mais effectivement on va dire ma
quel prix puisque on est arrivé à la
crise des dettes souveraines et que
après il a fallu remettre varié après on
a eu ce débat sur est-ce qu'il faut
continuer dans ces conditions donc en
effet et le bilan est mitigé de l'euro
maintenant il faut aussi on peut aussi
prendre du recul et se dire que
lorsqu'on regarde l'histoire américaine
eh bien eux aussi s'étaient pas si
évident au démarrage
d'ailleurs ce qui est drôle c'est que
les camps étaient en fait c'était en
termes d'éthique est politique et de
l'idée soutenue c est l inverse qui se
produisait donc à la fin du xviiie
siècle il y avait les mêmes batailles
fédéralisme anti fédéraliste mais ce
qu'il faut créer un un budget commun
mise des finances et et en fait c'était
plutôt le camp républicain et qui était
plutôt réservé sur v qui est qui qui
étaient excusés mois plus tôt pour avoir
cet état fédéral et parce qu'on disait
croient que cela favoriserait les le
financement des infrastructures voilà
c'était c'était hamilton qui avait cette
position alors que de l'autre côté on
avait des personnes qui étaient un anti
fédéraliste qui était plutôt démocrate
et qui lui était très réservé en disant
voilà le risque c'est la dette donc
c'est très drôle puisque voilà
aujourd'hui on a plutôt des discours qui
sont inversés sur le plan politique avec
toujours ce même cette même bataille
autour de la dette du fait de comment on
maîtrise cette dette et on voit donc
finalement l'histoire se répète donc on
peut se dire qu'on est peut-être audible
au début de finalement un pas un autre
pas en direction d'une autre europe
mais voilà donc cette bilan qu'on peut
tirer aujourd'hui on va passer à la
dernière excès de la semaine
21 année historique pour l'activité de
fusions acquisitions le volume mondial
des fusions et acquisitions a dépassé en
2021 pour la première fois les cinq
mille milliards de dollars avec une
valeur globale des transactions estimées
à 5800 milliards de dollars une hausse
de 64% par rapport à 2009 1 holliger
comment est-ce qu'on expliquer cette
envolée et puis peut-être rapidement
expliqué aurait expliqué en quoi
consiste concrètement la fusion
acquisition celle des entreprises qui se
mangent entre elles donc ça c'est assez
simple et
l'explication du fait qu' il y en ait
beaucoup elle est assez simple aussi
c'est à dire que vous avez énormément
d'argent qui est injecté dans les
circuits de moors de finances et serra
il doit aller se placer vous avez des
entreprises qui regorgent de cash et qui
donc en achètent d'autres et comme vous
avez aussi pas mal d'entreprises qui je
dirais son temps en difficulté donc
qui ont des bébés des prix qui sont
intéressants évidemment les grosses
entreprises en profitent et les achète
vous mêmes aujourd'hui vu le niveau
stratosphérique des cours boursiers les
payer avec rien c'est à dire avec de
l'argent magique qui est votre votre
titre en bourse donc ça ne vous coûte
absolument rien et vous pouvez comme ça
vous achetez la terre entière donc c'est
pas compliqué
et c'est assez normal c'est à dire que
quand vous avez tout cet argent qui est
justement fléchés vers un tout petit
nombre de deux d'entreprises et de
d'ultra riches
entreprises comme apple com comme amazon
com enfin les gars femme ex tard eh bien
il faut pas s'étonner que ces
entreprises la face aux recours si vous
voulez et donc qu'elle et qui est un
haut niveau de fusions acquisitions et
puis vous savez il ya un espèce de grand
de deux grandes croyances inquiets qui
est aussi que quand vous
fusionnez deux mules vous allez avoir un
cheval de course bon c'est alors ça n'a
jamais fonctionné ça n'a jamais marché
c'est ce qu'on appelle des défusions
défensive si vous voulez et qui ne sont
pas étonnants dans le moment qu'on vit
ou vous avez des entreprises qui se
retrouvent en difficulté et qui se
disent que allié avec une autre
entreprise qui a autant de difficultés
qu'elle est bien ils vont résoudre leurs
difficultés ensemble en général ça se
passe très mal mais on fait semblant d'y
croire pendant un petit moment
d'intelligence on est ce que ce haut
niveau de fusions acquisitions et
concrètement une bonne chose pour notre
économie est ce que ça a un impact
quelconque sur cette dernière alors le
niveau des fusions acquisitions et
effectivement on va voir ce que
donneront dans le futur c'est toujours
difficile de prévoir exactement leur
leur impact positif sur sur l'économie
puisque
et
parfois elles sont générées avec des
mauvaises perceptions comme les vielles
le rappeler ce n'est pas toujours une
bonne c'est pas toujours fait ce pour
des bonnes raisons il ya beaucoup
d'histoire en fait qui finissent à
sémalens fusions acquisitions néanmoins
l'année comme il ya eu en fait une pause
avec locaux vides il faut aussi se dire
faut relativiser le phénomène en se
disant que c'est aussi la raison pour
laquelle il y en a eu autant cette année
c'est parce qu'une a eu moins l'année
d'avant il ya une espèce d'effets de
rattrapage effet de rattrapage qui a été
effectivement accélérée par
la moindre activité de 2020 qui a mis
certaines sociétés sous pression et donc
du coup en 2021 quand il ya eu cette
cette possibilité d'avoir une activité à
nouveau à peu près normal mais bien et
c'est les projets ont fleuri donc en
fait c'est la conjonction de ces deux
choses le fait qu'il y en a eu moins et
qu' il y avait peut-être plus
d'opportunités pour pour qu'elle se
réalise alors en effet ce phénomène
s'inscrit aussi globalement dans cette
dans cette tendance qu'on observe depuis
maintenant presque depuis la crise de
2008 depuis qu'on a qu'on a refait
surface avec le la pléthore en fait
d'argent qui circule sur sur les marchés
financiers puisque effectivement la
politique des banques centrales à
travers des taux relativement bas et
avec une petite monétaire qui impacte en
premier le marché financier parce qu'en
fait c'est un peu la nouveauté de ces
politiques monétaires et bien vont à la
faveur des marchés financiers donc
effectivement ça explique que ça attire
beaucoup d'appétit toujours plus aux
etats unis quand même qu'en europe mais
effectivement en europe cette année on
avoir en france en particulier on a
conclu l'année avec cette fameuse
opération cette levée de fond de saut
rare dans le lait dans le secteur de nft
qui a fait une levée de fonds assez
importante et donc on observe dans tous
les pays merci beaucoup à nathalie
jenson à d'avoir été parmi nous dans
cette émission je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste et enseignante et chercheuse
à l'école de management neoma business
business school et options vous
retrouvera sur ce plateau la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle émission car
c'est la fin de celle ci n'est t'es pas
à réagir sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
hashtag rta cash à la semaine prochaine
et olivier en attendant on se quitte
avec votre mot de la fin écoutez d'abord
un à nouveau bonne bonne chance à tous
pour cette année et espérons que notre
chemin de croix se finisse dans trois
mois